[Musique]
Colomb les deux églises 14h43
à 400 m de l'église la Boisserie la
demeure acquise en 1933 par le
lieutenantconel De
Gaulle ici face à la plaine je retrouve
toute ma
sérénité l'engin blindé de
reconnaissance sur lequel est posé le
cercueil recouvert du drapeau est encore
dans le parc de La
Boisserie le vent souffle sur ce pays de
champagne que de feuilles mortes
descendu
aujourd'hui
les grilles de la Boisserie sont
ouverte
t
dever ta
tête
le cortège prend la rue du Général de
Gaulle et dans la foule ils sont des
milliers venus de toute la France pour
ce
moment-là il y a ici 350 Compagnons de
la Libération des survivants de l'ordre
qui en comptait un peu plus de 1000 ils
sont venus de tous les coins du monde
certains d'Amérique du Sud et la plupart
ne s'était pas vu depuis très
longtemps des hommes se signent d'autres
saluent d'autres font avec de doigt le V
de la
[Applaudissements]
victoire
immédiatement après l'engin blindé qui
porte le circueil du général de Gaulle
la première voiture est
celle où se trouve Madame De
Gaulle
vous voyez apparaître la voiture de
Madame De
Gaulle et dans un instant vous allez
voir le cortège passer devant le
cimetière et vous aperceverz la tombe où
tout à l'heure le général nebul sera
inhumé voici le
cimetière et voici la tombe les fleurs
blanches ont été déposé j'ai là à
l'intention de Anne de W la fille
enterrée ici en
vous allez voir dans un instant précédé
par l'évêque de
langangre Madame De
Gaulle et son fils Philippe le capitaine
de vaisseau Philippe De
Gaulle puis suivront le général de
Boissieux son
gendre sa femme les petits enfants dont
le jeune Charles de
Gaulle
ce sont 12 garçons de colombelle et de
églis qui vont porter le cercueil à
l'intérieur de
l'église
le saint-syrien qui suit le cercueil
porte lui le livre des Compagnons de la
Libération qui sera tout à l'heure
déposé sur le
cercueil cette église peut me recevoir
quelques 400 personnes
elle est un peu trop petite pour le
monde qui s est pressé cet après-midi un
grand nombre des compagnant de la
Libération étaai resté
[Musique]
debout c'est l'évêque de langangre
Monseigneur [__] qui a concélébré la
messe assisté du curé de Colombet et de
François de GA père blanc et neveu du
général
[Musique]
l
deš
[Musique]
deor
érousal
[Musique]
et au nom du Père et du Fils et du
Saint-Esprit
amen la paix soit avec vous mes frères
et avec votre
esprit
nous sommes réunis mes frères dans
l'unanimité de notre attachement et de
notre reconnaissance au général de
Gaulle que Dieu a rappelé à
lui
chrétien nous sommes unis plus
profondément
encore par notre foi en l'amour infini
de
Dieu c'est à lui que nous adressons
notre prière pour Charles de Gaulle pour
sa famille pour la
France afin de nous préparer à offrir le
sacrifice de la
Messe il nous faut d'abord mes
frères demander au
Seigneur d'avoir pitié de
nous d'oublier nos erreurs
nos péchés et de nous
pardonner seigneur prends pitié
elle est sur cette
parole si nous sommes morts avec lui
avec lui nous
vivrons si nous supportons lesé preuve
règnerons si nous sommes des
hautpleurss diffuseent à l'extérieur la
cérémonie pour ceux qui sont car sur la
place et même sur les toits de
Colombé Seigneur est la
grâce
l'abondance du
rachat c'est lui qui
rachètera
Israël de
toutes
deses je
je mon espoir dans le
Seigneur je suis s de sa
parole le Seigneur soit avec vous et
avec votre esprit etons notre cœur nous
le tournons vers le
Seigneur
vous voyez à gauche le capitaine de
vaisseau Philippe De Gaulle fils du
général et au premier plan cette ombre
agenouillée c'est est juste et bon de te
rendre gloire de t'offrir notre action
de grâce toujours et en tout lieu à toi
Père trèssint Dieu éternel et
tout-puissant par le Christ notre
Seigneur souviens-toi de Charles de
Gaulle que tu as appelé auprès de toi
aujourd'hui puisqu'il a été baptisé dans
la mort de ton fils accorde-lui de
participer à sa
résurrection le jour où le Christ
ressuscitant les morts rendra nos
pauvres corps pareil à son corps
[Musique]
glorieux madame de gale vient de
communier
puis d'autres membres de sa famille non
limité crois en toi mon
Dieu je crois en
toi
mystérieux
si près de
moi
ta
roi
[Musique]
tu en
moi
je crois en toi mon
Dieu
je crois
[Musique]
en Seigneur Jésus
que ton
jugement ne condamne pas notre frère
Charles devant toi qui donc serait
trouvé
juste si tu ne lui obtiens pas toi-même
le pardon de tous ses
péchés au nom de la vraie foi nous te
recommandons
humblement notre frère Charles de
gaulleis qu'il a vécu marqué du signe de
la Trinité qu'il échappe à la
condamnation par le secours de ta
grâce Seigneur toi qui vis et règnes
pour les siècles des siècles
Amen
lib
a
i
[Musique]
prent k do
CELI
mut
[Musique]
éement
15h50 la fin de la messe le circueil va
maintenant être porté au cimetière
toujours par les 12 jeunes gens de
[Musique]
Colombet
lumère
[Musique]
je nous
contemplons en ton
visage ton
amour derrière le cercueil s'avance
l'évêque de langangre
et à ses
côtés madame de gale
die
lumire
Dieu
notre
[Musique]
P nous
attendons dans
l'espér puis le général de boisseux sa
femme et la petite Anne suivie de
Charles de
[Musique]
Gaul puis la sœur aînée du général de
Gaulle dans quelques instants Charles de
Gaulle sera mise en terre dans cette
terre tourmentée dont il a si souvent
parlé dans ses mémoires
minutece
voilà c'est bien là l'inumation que
Charles de Gaul
souhaitait dans ce petit cimetière de
village près de sa fille dans cette
tombe qu'il voyait de sa fenêtre de la
Boisserie et que sans doute il regardait
parfois
golele
moi même s
est et quon et cro en moi ne pour
pas
Seigneur ok
seigneurèr la
prièreig notre Père qui est au cieux que
ton nom soit sanctifié que ton règne
vienne que ta volonté soit faite sur la
terre comme au ciel donnez-nous
aujourd'hui notre pain de ce jour
pardonnez-nous nos offenses comme nous
pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous ont
offensés et ne nous soumets pas à la
tentation mais délivre-nous du mal
Seigneur entend ma prière
le Seigneur soit avec
vous Seigneur notre
Dieu toi qui nous as
aimé tu as donné ton fil pour que tout
hommes qui croi en lui ne périsse pas
mais possède la vie
éternelle viens au secours de notre
faiblesse fais grandir dans la foi tous
ceux qui se confillent en un amour
et reçoit dans son paradis Charles de GA
t serviteur et notre
frère que la paix du Seigneur T avec
N
et parmi les membres de la famille après
la sœur aînée du général de Gaulle il y
a aussi pour le dernier adieu les deux
vieilles servantes
Bou pas sur le plateau
merci
16h9 la grille de la boicherie est
refermée tout était terminé la terre
sombre et humide du petit cimetière de
Colombet venait de retomber sur le
cercueil
tricolur jamais simplicité et
dépouillement n'avait atteint à autant
de grandeur et d'émotion les dernières
volontés du général de Gaulle exprimé
dans un testament longuement mûri avaiit
été respecté dans les moindres détails
il se fit ensuite à Colombet un long
instant de silence puis commença le lent
et interminable défilé de tous ceux qui
avaient fait le pèlerinage de Colomb et
deux églises devenu en ce jour le cœur
de la France à l'heure actuelle la nuit
est tombée depuis longtemps mais la
procession n'est pas achevée
retournons d'ailleurs quelques instants
en direct sur la tombe de
Colombet ici Colombet comme vous venez
de le dire la la procession n'est pas
encore achevée mais elle s'achèvera
bientôt les dernières volontés du
général de Gaulle ont été strictement
respectées jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire
que c'est dans le silence et la dignité
que 40000 peut-être 50000 hommes et
femmes venus des quatre coins de la
France ont rendu un dernier hommage à
Charles de
Gaul le défilé devant la tombe a
commencé dès la fin de l'office
religieux en tête bien sûr venaient les
Compagnons de la Libération portant
épingl sur la poitrine la plaquette de
bronze accrochée par le ruban vert et
noir et derrière eux c'était la foule
une foule digne silencieuse qui
pénétrait en rang par deux à l'intérieur
de ce petit cimetière de campagne qui
évidemment n'avait pas été prévu pour un
tel
hommage
à plusieurs reprises les haut-parleurs
du service d'ordre encourageaient la
foule à se disperser à rejoindre les
autocars et a abandonné l'idée de
défiler ce soir devant la
tombe ces recommandations furent assez
peu
écouté comme me disait un Français libre
venait venu de Bretagne ce n'est quand
même pas aujourd'hui que nous allons
abandonner à la dernière
heure rares furent ceux qui renonçaient
ce défilé risque encore de se prolonger
pendant une heure
environ mais ici à Colombet l'ambiance
n'est pas aux grandes phrases ni Hélie
ni auison funèbre ni discours avit
demandé le général de Gaulle je préfère
donc m'imposer le silence pour vous
laisser méditer quelques instants sur
ces dernières images de Colombé et vous
permettre d'avoir vous aussi
l'impression de vous incliner devant
cette
tombe
ici Colombet à vous
Paris alors qu'à Colombé battait cet
après-midi le cœur de la France Paris ce
matin avait été pour quelques heures la
capitale de l' univers dans Notre-Dame
de Paris devenu Notre-Dame du monde 80
souverains chef d'État et chef de
gouvernement s'était réuni là ce matin
pour adresser un ultimonage aux plus
illustres des Français jamais une
cérémonie du souvenir n'avait réuni en
un même lieu autant de souverains autant
de chefs de gouvernement à côté du
président Nixon ou du chadiran du
président potegorny ou de la reine
Juliana il y avait aussi ceux qui ont
quitté le pouvoir mais qui a un moment
donné avait participé à l'histoire au
côté du général de Gaulle l'Israélien
benouron l'allemand herart
idden
l'anglais et pourtant conformément au
vœux du général de Gaulle cette messe de
récuyem sans en raison ni absoute fut
d'autant plus émouvante qu'elle était
plus
simple tôt ce matin avant même les
premières lueur de l'aube des centaines
puis des milliers puis des dizaines de
milliers de Parisiens sétaient assemblé
dans toutes les rues avoisinant la
cathédrale Notre-Dame où devait être
célébré à 11h le service solennel à la
mémoire du général de
Gaulle dans cette foule nombreux étaient
ceux qui avaient espéré pouvoir entrer
dans la cathédrale où les bas côtés
avaient été réservés au public il fallut
fermer les portes quelques minutes après
les avoir ouvertes 3000 personnes
avaient pu pénétrer on ne pouvait en
recevoir davantage pour les autres il ne
restait que les trottoirs de la place et
des
rues la tente debout et le froid vif du
petit matin provoquèrent quelques
évanouissements les malades furent
évacués par la police dans les poste de
secours de la
[Musique]
CroixRouge seul Lesnes mies d'invitation
P franchir les
grilles parmi elles il y avait plusieurs
portes
drapeau les autres dont le nom ne
cessait de grossir étit difficilement
contenu par le service
d'ordre
j'espéis d'assister à la cérémonie
religieuse mais on pe pas entrer alors
je suis venu de B lieu mais je suis
depis 8h3 rien à faire nous ne pouvons
pas entrer ça na pas d'importance nous
sommes ici pour faire un hommage
monsieur vous allez les mettre où ces
fleurs elles sont dtiné à la mémoire du
général de GA moire du général de GA et
j'aurais voulu pouir rentrer ces
fleursellement à la cathédrale oui vous
êtes arrivé à quelle heure pour assister
à
l'ICE
ce matin et vous n'alz plus pouvoir
rentrer maintenant c'estàdire qu'il faut
qu'on attende ce soirend attendra ce
soir s'il faut on attendra que la
cérémonie soit terminée pour pouvoir
défoser la gerbe à
l'hôtel sous les voûtes de Notre Dame
tendue de tricolore peu après 10h le
prince réier en jaquette sombe
traversait le premier la grande allée
centrale bordée de garde républicain le
sabre au cler c'est suite le long défilé
des souverains et chefs d'État le Roi
Baudouin le frère du prince Hussein du
roi Hussein le président de
Siran l'empereur
aéaciier la reine Juliana le prince de
Gall le président Nixon conduit par
Monseigneur
pzeril Monsieur pogorny le Chef de
l'État
soviétique salué par Monsieur kekonen le
Président de la République
finlandaise le chat d'Iran ils sont 80
chefs d'étail de gouvernement venu
rendre hommage à celui que le président
Nixon appelait un géant parmi les
hommes un silence lourd de souvenir
entoure ces hommes cependant qu'à 11h le
président de la République qui est
Madame Pompidou arrivrive accueilli par
le cardinal Marti qui a revêtu la
chasuble violette signe du
deuil le président de la République a un
siège réservé dans le
cœur cependant que Madame Pompidou est
légèrement en
retrait le visage recueill an qu'il
s'agisse de personnages connus ou anonym
[Musique]
médit
le gouvernement est là au grand complet
derrière le président Chaban d'mas les
présidents des assemblées le corps
diplomatique les corps constitués la
messe sera simple dite par le cardinal
Marti sans
homélie simplement à un moment une
invitation à la
[Musique]
méditation la maîtrise des enfants de
NotreDame exécute les cœurs
spécial
[Musique]
desats-unis notre assemblée à laquelle
s'unissent des millions d'hommes en
France et dans le monde
prouve quelle place tenait celui qui
vient d'être appelé sous ement dans son
éternité il a
sollicité notre
silence il a voulu l'homble intercession
de la communauté
chrétienne confessant le péché nous
prions Dieu de donner son pardon et sa
paix
don
[Musique]
la MEL se déroule dite en
français les prières sont lues par le
cardinal Marti ou le Chapelin de notre
[Musique]
Mame c'est un évangile de Saint-Jean qui
sera lu un évangile
[Musique]
d'espérance
après les évation ce sera la
[Musique]
communion pour la première fois dans une
cérémonie
officielle la communion va être
distribué à tous les assistants qui le
[Musique]
désirent plusieurs prêtres vont prendre
sur l'Hôtel Des sibois remplis de
centaines
[Musique]
d'osti V
communier madame
Pompidou le Roi
[Musique]
Baudouin
le président de sirane plusieurs
présidents
africains des proches du général de
Gaulle de nombreuses
personnalités et des centaines et des
centaines de fidèles
inconnus les représentants des autres
cultes orthodoxes protestants islamiques
israélit sont présents dans cette église
catholique croyant de toute nature ou
incroyant cet instant est pour tous
véritablement un instant de
[Musique]
communion après les condoléances
présentées par les représentants des
différents cultes au président de la
République c'est la fin de
l'office cependant que
retentit un dernier Coral de
Jean-Sébastien
B le président de la République et
Madame Pompidou vont sortir les premiers
de la
cathédrale conduit par le cardinal
François
[Musique]
Marty discrtement d'une légère
inclination de tête le président de la
République a salué au passage toutes les
personnalités présentes dans la
cathédrale puis c'est la
sortie de tous les
fidèles
[Musique]
cependant que sonne au clocher de Notre
Dame le
[Musique]
glas le président de la République n'a
pas caché son émotion durant toute la
cérémonie il était bouleversé et sur le
sur le parvis comme s'ils étaient venus
enterrer un proche ils s'arrêt quelques
instants t ces personnages illustres se
salut échange quelques
[Musique]
propos et jusque dans ces images on
retrouve cette simplicité ce
dépouillement qu'avait souhaité le
général de
[Musique]
Gaulle le protocole oublié un instant
réuni dans la même tion ceux qui ont
franchi parfois des distances
considérables pour s'associer
aujourd'hui au deuil de tous les
[Musique]
Français
de NotreDame de Paris à la plus petite
église de campagne c'est donc la France
tout entière qui s'est rassemblé pour
dire adieu au libérateurs des années
sombres Marseille Lyon Bordeaux Lille
Nancy aucune grande ville n'a manqué au
souvenir et c'était partout le même
recueillement et la même émotion mais
certains de ces hommages ont peut-être
été encore un peu plus touchants que les
autres à Paris à midi aujourd'hui les
autobus se sont arrêté pendant une
minute c'est la manière dont le
personnel de la RATP voulait marquer son
hommage au général de Gaulle à Orly ce
matin un peu avant 11h les haut-parleurs
de l'aérogard ont cessé d'annoncer les
départs et les arrivées des avions pour
faire savoir qu'une messe allait être
dite dans les regards et on a vu des
hommes et des femmes en transit venant
des quatre coins du monde assister à
cette cérémonie et apporter leur homage
personnel à Charles de
Gaulle mais ce deuil que la France tout
entière a célébré ce deuil une commune
un village l'a ressenti probablement
beaucoup plus encore que tous les autres
et ce village bien sûr c'est Colombé les
deux
églises
[Musique]
ils étaient là bien avant l'aube
plusieurs milliers qui pour un dernier
salut au libérateurs de la France
n'avaent pas hésité à arriver pour
certains dès mercredi
soir
[Musique]
il se tenait là debout certains
enveloppés dans une couverture le
thermomètre dépassait à peine zéro la
nuit
dernière ils étaient venus de tous les
coins de France de Paris de Marseille
beaucoup d'étrangers aussi beaucoup
d'Allemands et tout au long de la
matinée le long pèlerinage allait se
poursuivre on laissait sa voiture le
long de la route quelquefois à plusieurs
kilomètres de Colombet pour finir le
chemin à pied mais peu importait pour
ces fidèles qui avaient voulu l'être
jusqu'au dernier instant les plus
heureux avaient trouvé une place de
parking dans ces parcs improvisés en
plein
champ le plus étonnant c'était ce
silence qui planait sur le petit village
malgré toute cette foule 40000 50000
personnes peut-être tous mêlés des
jeunes et des moins jeunes ancien de la
France Libre
saint-syien compagnon de la première
heure ils étaient là aussi commerçants
qui avaient fermé boutique pour la
journée paysan de champagne de ceux que
le général de Gaulle aimait à rencontrer
dans sa campagne autour de
[Musique]
Colombet Français anonymes tous réunis
dans le même souvenir dans le même
silence et dans ce recueillement les
seuls que l'on voyait se dépêcher
c'était les membres du service de
premiier secours plusieurs centaines
d'interventions pour la plupart des
Malais cardiaque dû à la fatigue dû
aussi à
[Musique]
l'émotion pour être présent à Colombet
une dernière fois d'autres avaient
choisi de venir en train ainsi de Paris
5000 parisiens au moins arrivés ce matin
par H trains
[Musique]
spéciaux
l'essentiel c'est d'aller à Colomb
porter témoignage et puis le reste ah
oui mais vraiment ça fait plaisir savez
ça fera certain tellement plaisir notre
c'est gentil notreame c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas l'action c'est pas le
mouvement Notre Dame c'est très bien
très bien mais ce n'est pas ça pas ça
c'est pas lui
c'est moi j'ai pas regretté j'ai pas
regardé à firemer bon commerce
aujourd'hui je m'en fiche moi vous savez
fermé ma porte et je suis parti et puis
c'est tout de Gaulle pour moi c'est un
symbole c'est un grand homme et jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours on le vénéra mes
enfants le vénéreront et dans l'histoire
il laissera sa place jusquau ou rés je
suis partie de chez moi il était 5h je
n'ai pas d'heure pour partir quand c'est
comme ça il y a rien qui me retient vous
savez surtout pour le général de Gaulle
vous seriez parti plus tôt oh j'aurais
passé la nuit dehors par n'importe quel
temps la puie averse tout ce qu'on
aurait voulu m à en mourir ça ne ferait
rien il était si bon
si brave vous savez qu'est-ce qu'il n'a
pas fait pour nous
tous les Français les Français on
devrait avoir du cœur vous
savez ça représente quoi pour vous cette
mort une grosse
peine une grosse
peine plus émouvant encore le dernier
train celui parti de Paris à 11h35
menant vers colombelle les deux églises
les Compagnons de la
[Musique]
Libération les Compagnons de la
Libération le général de GA leur avait
réserver la place d'honneur dès
[Musique]
1952 combien de compagnons ont pris le
train spécial pour aujourd'hui environ
vous pensez qu'à peu près tous les
compagnons qui sont en vie seront à
Colom il en est venu de tous les coins
de Bangkok de Djibouti il en est venu de
du Kenya et quelle que soit l'opinion
politique puisque vous voyez aujourd'hui
vous en avez de tout origine monsieur
alband Vistel vous êtes compagnon de la
Libération le général de a tenu
expressément à ce que les Compagnons de
la Libération assiste à ces obsèques
est-ce que cette dernière volonté vous a
surpris tout d'abord elle m'a bouleversé
n'estce pas parce qu'elle atteste une
telle fidélité à notre égard et un tel
sens de la fraternité que j'en été
bouleversé c'est un bruit qui courit
depu très longtemps que les compagnons
sert présents le jour où il
disparaîtrait puisquil l'avait laissé en
quels sont vos sentiments vous prenez ce
train spécial pour les obsèques du
général c'est un sentiment
d'émotion d'assister aux obsèques du
général qui fait le chèque de la France
libre de 40 à 45 est-ce que sa
décision de désigner expressément ses
compagnons pour assister aux obsèes vous
a surpris non
elle était conforme à ce qu'il avait
voulu je crois depuis longtemps honorer
ceux qui les premiers l'avaient rejoint
qui n'avaient jamais mis en question le
sort de la
France la radio et la télévision on
réunit aujourd'hui tous ceux qui pour
des raisons diverses n'avaient pu se
rendre à Notre-Dame ou à Colomb les deux
[Musique]
églises peu de monde dans les rues de
Paris si ce n'est de petits groupes qui
se sont formés devant les boutiques de
télévision partout des visages
graves ce de ceux qui ont combattu sous
ces ordres ceux pour qui il a été une
raison de vivre aux heures sombres de la
guerre ceux aussi des enfants pour qu'il
est tout simplement le général de
Gaulle or à d'oursurglan la ville
martyre rendait aussi hommage à celui
qui fut fut le premier personnage
officiel à l'avoir reconnu à lui avoir
reconnu le droit de justice à la fin de
la guerre et qui en 1962 écrivait sur le
livre d'or de la commune pour Oradour
surglan en toute émotion et en toute
confiance nationale horadour qui fut
incendié par les Allemands le 10 juin
1944 après qu'ils eurent massacré 634
habitants en fin de matinée le maire
accompagné par tr escapé toute la
population neposa des gerbes en forme de
croix de Lorine au pied du monument au
mort dans la nouvelle
[Musique]
ville à l'île de sain tandis que le
glaranis dans les ruelles désertes de la
petite île tous les sénan étaient
retrouvés une nouvelle nouvelle fois
dans la petite église tous réunis une
dernière fois derrière Charles de
Gaulle réunis comme le 24 juin 1940
lorsque 127 d'entre eux avaient pris la
mer pour l'Angleterre pour la France
[Musique]
libre
ici à Saint le dernier geste à la
mémoire du général de Gaulle devait être
une simple gerbe déposée au pied du
monument rappelant pour toujours la
réponse des cénant en juin
[Musique]
même cérémonie simple même croix de
Lorine à bordeau méignac c'est d'ici que
le 17 juin 1940 est parti pour Londres
le général de
Gaulle français n'oubliez jamais
le premier résistant de France le
général de Gaulle parti afin de
continuer la
lutte
au même moment cet après-midi on se
souvenait aussi en Normandie à cour seul
c'est ici sur cette plage le 14 juin
1944 presque 4 ans jour pour jour après
son départ de Bordeaux mrigac que le
général de Gaulle a retrouvé la terre de
France ce jour-là la plupart des
Français devait découvrir un visage il
ne connaissait depuis 4 ans que la voix
du
général fidèle au testament c'est un
office très simple qui s'est déroulé
dans la petite église de courseul en
présence du seul conseil
[Musique]
municipal contraste ici à Lille Lille la
ville qui a vu naître le général de
Gaulle
son courage de soldat affronta tant de
tempêtes pour le service de notre
pays qu'il connaisse désormais la paix
inaltraable du Royaume de
Dieu après l'office les fidèles à Lille
comme dans toute la France pouvait se
presser devant les registres pour une
dernière signature un dernier hommage au
général de Gaulle deuil national dans
toute la France et ceux pourtant qui
travaillaient aujourd'hui n'ont pas
oublié ainsi dans cette usine de bourge
par exemple à 11h les 282 ouvriers
debout ont respecté une minute de
silence
enfin Toulouse Toulouse qui devait à sa
façon honorer le général de Gaulle qui
plus que tout autre avait tant cru aux
Concordes Paris est l'une des cinq
villes de France titulaires de l'Ordre
de la Libération Paris est donc
compagnon de la Libération et Paris a
voulu par un hommage exceptionnel au
général de Gaulle organiser derrière son
conseil municipal unanime un défilé
silencieux du rond-point des
Champs-Élysées à la place de l'Étoile 5
minutes avant 18h l'heure prévue du
rassemblement une pluie diluvienne
s'abattait sur la capitale elle n'a pas
courage décour AG des centaines de
milliers de Parisiens et de parisiennes
revoyons les premiers instants de cette
manifestation dans la nuit tombée dans
cette pluie de novembre c'est le murmure
d'une ville la voix de Paris qui porte
encore ce soir le nom de Charles de
Gaulle inumé dans sa terre tout à
l'heure comme le plus humble des
habitants du plus simple village de
France après l'hommage des grands du
monde réunis ce matin en communion de
souvenir en la nef de Notre-Dame de
Paris après l'hommage de tous les hommes
et les femmes de France dans la
déchirante simplicité de l'église de
Colombé c'était ce soir Paris rassemblé
sur cette voie royale des Champs-Élysées
dans le l cheminement du respect
profond 18h ils étaient des centaines de
milliers à répondre à l'appel du
président du Conseil de Paris qui
invitait la population de Paris
compagnon de la Libération à se
rassembler dans le silence pour cette
marche vers l'étoile pour dép poser une
dernière gerbe sur la dalle du soldat
inconnu des gerbes il y en a par
milliers des fleurs par
millions et pourtant ce soir la flamme
n'a pas été ranimée à 18h30 précise
comme cela se fait chaque soir de paix
ou de guerre chaque soir depuis 50 ans
ce soir ils étaient trop nombreux en ce
grand
moment
ils étaient là la pluie et les larmes
mêlés sur le visage tous les conseiller
de Paris la poitrine barrée de tricolore
tous les anciens combattants à 18h30 la
foule grossissait toujours
innombrable la pluie n'en a découragé
aucun ils sont jeunes recueill qui March
avec des regards brillants ils ont subi
les épreuves du combat en portant les
stigmates à leur poitrine ils arborent
haut les étendards qu'il suivaient jadis
tous mêlés ceux qui marchent en cortège
ceux qui se sont assemblés sur les
trottoirs par centaines de milliers pour
se
recueillir aucand de n'a voulu partir
sans laisser un témoignage chaque geste
est un hommage aux fleurs officielles
fleurs en couronne s'ajoutent ces
bouquets quelques roses quelques fleurs
simples que l'on a protégé sous un
manteau tant bien que mal de la pluie
pour les joindre épanoui aux gerbes du
souvenir ils sont venus des quartiers de
Paris des banlieux éloignés venus à pied
sous le vent et la pluie tous harborent
les trois couleurs un foulard noué
autour du cou un un simple ruban
tricolore à la boutonnière quelques
fleurs comment canaliser cette foule
jamais vue aussi dense en cet endroit
cette foule où chacun voulait être là
aveuglé par la pluie pour participer une
dernière
fois c'est sur ces images d'une foule
spontanée que s'est terminé cette humble
cérémonie du recueil
terminé pas tout à fait puisque à 20h45
maintenant jerois je crois qu'il reste
encore beaucoup de monde sur les champs
éélysées pour nous en assurer nous
allons nous y rendre quelques instants à
nouveau en direct
oui il y a autour du tombeau du soldat
inconnu autour de ces fleurs de ces
crois de la reine de ces fleurs jeté de
ces fleurs amoncelé de ces fleurs du
souvenir et du respect il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de monde énormément de
monde le défilé n'a jamais cessé à un
moment donné il était peut-être 19h20
19h25 juste après la fin de notre
reportage en direct à un moment donné
les gens se dispersèrent parce que la
pluie vraiment était affreuse et puis
ils sont revenus ils sont revenus et ils
continue de venir il continue de défiler
les Champs-Élysées sont noirs de monde
pourevenir ici s'incliner devant la
tombe de l'inconnu et je me rappelle ces
mots du général de Gaulle lorsqu'il il
descendait les champs d'élysée le 26
août 1944 quand il disait c'est la mer
une foule immense émassée de part et
d'autre de la chaussée peut-être 2
millions d'âmes si loin que porte ma vue
ce n'est qu'une roule vivante et bien
c'est cela aujourd'hui sauf que les gens
montent et sauf peut-être
que il y a eu une espèce de mise en
ordre une espèce de canalisation de la
foule tout à l'heure les gens se
pressaient se bousculaient presque
autour de la dalle sacrée maintenant on
a réussi à les canaliser
et
l'hommage pour être un peu moins
désordonné n'en reste pas moins émouvant
et je crois que les Parisiens peuvent
venir ici pendant encore plusieurs
heures pendant plusieurs heures il y
aura ici du monde et lorsque ce monde
aura commencé à diminuer il y aura
encore ici des gens qui viendront par
petit groupe et je pense que ce défilé
durera jusqu'au milieu de la nuit sinon
plus tard et de Gaulle disait encore
d'ici de ce lieu symbolique de tente et
de tant d'autres qui ont choisi la même
gloire dans la même humilité groupés
autour de celui-là dont Dieu seul sait
le nom et qui sous la flamme sacrée
représente la fleur de notre race abatue
dans les premiers combats de cette
guerre escorté par les ombres de T ceux
qui depuis 2000 ans donnèrent leur vie
pour défendre le corps et l'âme de la
patrie voici donc ses morts assemblés et
aujourd'hui autour de cette croix de
Lorine autour de ces fleurs autour de la
dalle sacrée les Parisiens se sont
assemblés en un nombre incalculable
plusieurs centaines de milles je le
pense
et le défilé le l défilé du souvenir et
du respect va
continuer
cette foule était si nombreuse si dense
que nous avons dû interrompre notre
premier reportage tout à l'heure en
direct et Monsieur Maurice Druon qui
avait accepté de participer à cet
hommage de Paris au général de Gaulle en
commentant ce reportage n'a pu associer
tous ceux qui d'une façon ou d'une autre
dans la guerre comme dans la paix quel
que soit leurage et Fû seulement par la
pensée comme le prouver la présence de
tant de femmes et de tant d'enfants de
France que tous ceux tous ceux qui ont
participé à l'action historique du
général de GA à cet hommage individuel
des parisiennes et des Parisiens des
Françaises et desfançais il faut ajouter
l'hommage de tous les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement venus représenter leur pays
aux obsèques du général de Gaulle et cet
après-midi tous les rois tous les chefs
de gouvernement tous les ministres des
Affaires étrangères sont allés à
l'Élysée présenter leur condoléance au
président et à Madame
Pompidou jamais on avait vu un tel
défilé de chef d'État à l'Élysée défilé
ouvert en début d'après-midi par le
président américain Nixon suivi du
président soviétique pod Gorny monsieur
Pompidou a en effet commencé par
recevoir en audience privée h chefs
d'État et gouvernement le président
italien saragat la reine Juliana de
Hollande le premier britannique monsieur
HTH le premier indien madame Gandhi le
président allemand heoman et le Roi
Baudouin de Belgique ces entretiens ont
duré de 10 à 15 minutes chacun sauf les
deux premiers qui ont eu un caractère
politique celui avec Monsieur Nixon qui
a duré 45 minutes et celui avec Monsieur
Podgorny qui a duré 25
minutes lors de sa première sortie le
président Nixon n'a voulu faire aucune
déclaration mais le président Pony lui a
parlé les thmes abord au cours de votre
conversation j'ai ten à en mon nom au
nom de mes amis au nom de tout le peuple
soviétique nos profondes condéances à
l'asion du décès de cet homme d'État
hors père qui a été le général de
Gaulle récemment monsieur Pompidou a été
en visite officielle en URSS nous avons
eu avec lui des discussions très
détaillées et évidemment nous sommes
revenu à l'objet de nos discussions
d'alors nous avons évoqué ces rencontres
et parl de l'application des décisions
qui ont été alors adopté nous avons
constaté que déjà des choses se passent
entre nous j'ai exprimé au président
notre désir de voir s'appliquer de la
meilleure manière qui soit les accords
[Musique]
Conus et monsieurg a terminé en
souhaitant beaucoup de bonheur et
beaucoup de santé au peuple
français à 17 réception officielle et
dans la cour de l'éée se f un carous
ininterrompu de voiture des dizaines et
des dizaines de souverain de chefs
d'État de gouvernement sont venus
présenter le Condé au président la
République c'est la reine Juliana qui a
ouvert le défilé dans le salon Mura à
17h15 vous avez vu le monseigneur
macarios le chef d'État chipriotte Sa
Majesté Impériale le chadiran voici le
président
potgorny puis le prince Charles
l'héritier d'Élisabeth
d'Angleterre
madame Indira Gandhi Premier ministre de
l'Inde monsieur bouteflica ministre des
Affaires étrangères
algériens le président allemand
eineman parmi tant d'autres chef d'État
africain monsieur bkasa République
centrafricaine de l'extrême monsieur Hai
ministre des Affaires étrangères du
Japon monsieur tiranana le Président de
Madagascar monsieur Nixon monsieur
pombidou a fait un pas en avant pour
l'accueillir
le président Léopold
singor et Monsieur
benourion vous étiez personnellement lié
avec le général de Gaulle en effet
j'ai
d'honneur et le plaisir de connaître C
grand hommes depuis depuis la guerre les
années de la
guerre c'est normal que je vienne rendre
hommage au général en
représentant mon pays un ami de la
France ainsi qu'à titre
personnel et en faisant cela c'est au
fond rendre hommage à à la France à son
histoire
peut-être cet esprit de chevalier sans
peur et sans reproche que nous
aimerionsirselquesot je suis très
heureux d'avoir eu l'occasion de venir
pour présenter les respect du peuple
américain etes propres hommages à la
mémoire du général de GA le fait que
defé soit venu exprimer l'énorme
contribution que le général de Gaul a
apporté à son pays mais aussi au grands
principes auquel nous
croyons j'espère seulement que mon très
bref séjour ici exprime le respect
immense que le nom de de Gaul suscite
auprès de millions de mes C mais aussi
le respect qu'il commande auprès de
millions de personnes du monde entier
qu'il n'a jamais pu
rencontrer les siècles passent mais
l'histoire compte peu de très grands
hommes il n'y a aucun doute il a été
l'un des plus grands parmi les grands et
quand un tel homme nous quitte c'est un
grand privilège que de s'associer à ce
qui le
pleurent président
etis monsieur Nixon a ajouté j'espère en
tout cas revenir à Paris dans des
circonstances moins tristes monsieur le
Président qu'en pensez-vous pouvoir
venir rien de précis pour le moment mais
vous savez je ne manque jamais une
occasion de venir à Paris
80 chefs d'État et de gouvernement
réunis à Paris par de là les divergences
qui opposent certains d'entre eux c'est
ainsi que ce matin le président Nixon et
le président pogorny le chef de l'État
soviétique se sont rencontrés pendant 20
minutes aussitôt après la messe de réc à
Notre Dame mais au-delà de l'hommage de
ces personnalités officielles qui
représentaient leur pays il y a eu
aujourd'hui presque partout dans le
monde dans pratiquement toutes les
capitale du monde des cérémonies du
souvenir en mémoire du général le Gaulle
l'un dé Gest les plus remarqué
incontestablement a été l'hommage
personnel rendu par le président
masitung qui a adressé un télégramme
personnel à Madame De Gaulle de son côté
le Premier ministre chinois monsieur
schwen laay et plusieurs membres du
gouvernement de Pékin se sont rendus à
l'ambassade de France pour se recueillir
devant le portrait du gén général de
gale dans tous les pays d'Afrique
francophone c'était aujourd'hui journée
de deuil national des services ont été
célébrés dans les cathédrales de toutes
les capitales africaines au ProcheOrient
arabes et israéliens se sont retrouvés
pour un jour pour une journée de deuil
messe de récuyem au Ker messe à Haman
messe à Beyrouth dans l'église
Saint-Louis des Français messe aussi
bien sûr à Jérusalem et puis il faudrait
citer toutes les capitales du monde
communiste il faudrait citer Moscou
Budapest Varsovie il faudrait citer les
capitales occidentales Ottawa Washington
bon lae la mémoire du général de Gaulle
a été honorée jusque dans les coins les
plus retirés les plus éloignés de la
France un exemple un solul à l'extrémité
du subcontinent IEN un petit pays qui
s'appelle Sellan et dont on parle peu et
bien là-bas à Sellan aujourd'hui tous
les drapeaux étaient en berne et enfin
bien sûr Londres c'est de là-bas que le
18 juin 1940 parti le message qui sur
donner aux Français le goût de la
victoire et durant les 4 années
terribles de la guerre des liens
personnels s'étaienttissés entre Charles
de Gaulle et le peuple britannique et il
était normal qu'aujourd'hui l'hommage
rendu par l'Angleterre fut un hommage
peut-être plus important
qu'ailleurs c'est surtout ce soir dans
les programmes d'information que les
Britanniques regarderont sur leur chaîne
de télévision les obsèques du général de
Gaul néanmoins ce matin et cet
après-midi ceux d'entre eux qui étaient
disponibles pas manqué de suivre les
retransmissions en direct et se sont
joints par l'intermédiaire du petit
écran à la foule des Français en
deuil il règ sur la
création tous les Français de Londres
ont été conviés à une messe de récuem ce
matin à 11h ils sont venus très nombreux
dans cette église de Notre-Dame de
France où le chef de la France Libre
s'était si souvent recueilli durant la
guerre demandons à Dieu de faire de nous
à l'image du général de Gaulle de
patients ouvri de la paix et de la
justice c'est en ces termes que le Père
noblais Supérieur de la paroisse a
invité les nombreux fidèles parmi
lesquels des Britanniques à prier et à
se
recueillir Monseigneur boiguérin de
Liverpool officiait au côté du père
Noblet dans le cœur quatre drapeaux
français avaient été placés au-dessus de
l'hôtel à Édimbourg une messe de récuyem
a également été célébrée dans la
cathédrale Sainte
Marie comme la plupart des personnalités
françaises et britanniques se trouvent
absent de Londres aujourd'hui pour les
obsèques le gouvernement britannique a
décidé de prévoir un office spécial à la
mémoire du général de Gaulle à la
cathédal Saint-Paul le 19 novembre à
midi où elles seront
conviées nous allons rejoindre
maintenant Colombet les deux églises qui
est qui est pour quelques heures la
capitale de la France c'est par ces mots
que le présentateur de la télévision
canadienne a annoncé au téléspectateur
canadien la diffusion en direct par
satellite des obsèques du général de
Gaulle 18 pays d'Europe dans l'URSS 4
pays d'Amérique don les États-Unis le
Japon la Tunisie le Maroc ont repris les
images en couleur diffusé par l' RTF au
total 300 millions de téléspectateurs
estimenton ont suivi les cérémonies de
NotreDame de Paris et de Colombet cette
mondiision est la plus importante que la
France est jamais
organisée
cas
direct de
ah à
laes voix ne sont que quelques parmi des
dizaines cell des envoyés spéciaux de
toutes les télévisions du monde qui av
tôt ce matin envahi nos studios pour
commenter en direct les obsèques du
général de Gaulle pas moins de 35 pays
dont les États-Unis où c'était la nuit
lorsque commençait à Notre-Dame de Paris
l'office religieux on pu voir en direct
donc en même temps que vous les images
tourné par nos
équipes un demi mililliard de personnes
selon les dernières estimations dans le
monde ont pu capter ces images et dans
les prochaines heures ce sont encore des
centaines de millions de personnes qui
les verront en différé en raison des
décalages hora de Dublin à Madrid de New
York à Tokyo de Rio à Tunis de Moscou à
Raba par l'Eurovision par satellite
c'est bien la planète qui était
aujourd'hui au rendez-vous de
l'Histoire attention lex on va bientôt
arrêter voilà nous avons je pense rendu
le plus exactement compte possible des
différentes manif station qui ont marqué
cette journée de deuil national avant de
reprendre sur nos deux chaînes le
programme spécial qui sera suivi d'un
journal télévisé commun où vous pourrez
revoir quelques-uns des reportages que
nous avons déjà diffusés il faut nous
arrêter quelques instants et nous
intéresser si nous le pouvons à quelques
autres aspects de l'actualité du monde
le temps de la guerre des crise n'est
hélas pas oublié et une dépêche bien
inquiétante nous est arrivée ce soir du
C en effet pour pour la première fois le
président de la République arabe unie a
reconnu que son pays avait profité du
cesser le feu pour renforcer ses
positions militairees je vous cite les
propos de Monsieur hanouir el Sadat qui
s'adressait aujourd'hui au congrès
général de l'Union Socialiste arabe nous
avons grandement mis à profit le cesser
lefeu pour nous renforcer et cela
apparaîtra au moment opportun nous ne
laisserons échapper aucune occasion pour
nous renforcer et nous ne resterons pas
les bras croisés devant les
fortifications en entreprise par Israël
pour consolider ses positions a ajouté
le président el Sadat une dépêche qui
nous vient de la Cité du Vatican
monsieur André hiigromico ministre des
Affaires étrangères du RSS a été reçu
aujourd'hui en audience par le pape Paul
6 des des nouvelles de Luna 17 qui
poursuit sa route en direction de la
lune Luna 17 a maintenant franchi plus
de la moitié de la distance terre lune
et il semble que Luna 17 en même un
certain nombre d'expériences
supplémentaires en plus de ce qu'il doit
faire comme lunass c'est-à-dire
recueillir des échantillons de sol
lunaire et les ramener sur terre
Concorde
002 le second prototype de l'appareil
britannique franco-britannique
supersonic a atteint aujourd'hui Mac 2
le vol s'est extrêmement bien passé donc
8 jours après le Mac 2 de Concorde 001
enfin une dernière dépêche qui fera
réfléchir tous les pirates de l'air en
puissance l'ex marine italo-américain
raphaelll minichiello qui le 30 octobre
1969 détourna en plein vol un Boeing 707
de la TW de San Francisco à Rome a été
condamné aujourd'hui par le tribunal de
Rome à 7 ans et 6 mois de
prison depuis ce mardi 10 novembre au
matin où la nouvelle de la mort du
général de Gaulle a pétrifié le monde
entier il est une phrase qui est souvent
revenue dans les déclarations des hommes
d'État étrangers des personnalités
françaises ou dans les réflexions de
français inconnu une page est tournée
une grande page de l'histoire de France
il n'y avait donc d'autres manières pour
nous de porter témoignage de ce moment
de l'histoire qu'en unissant nos efforts
au moment où la France tout entière se
rassemblait dans le souvenir du général
de Gaulle et c'est le sens que nous
avons voulu donner à ce travail en
commun de 24hur sur la 2 et
d'information
[Musique]
première
Colomb les deux églises
[Musique]
14h43 à 400 m de l'église la Boisserie
la demeure acquise en 1933 par le
lieutenantconel De
Gaulle ici face à la plaine je retrouve
toute ma
sérénité l'engin blindé de de
reconnaissance sur lequel est posé le
cercueil recouvert du drapeau est encore
dans le parc de La
Boisserie le vent souffle sur ce pays de
champagne que de feuilles mortes
descendu
aujourd'hui
les grilles de la Boisserie sont
ouvertes
ta tête devant
làer ta
[Musique]
tête pas ATT
le cortège prend la rue du Général de
Gaulle et dans la foule ils sont des
milliers venus de toute la France pour
ce moment
là il y a ici 350 Compagnons de la
Libération des survivants de l'ordre qui
en comptait un peu plus de 1000 ils sont
venus de tous les coins du monde
certains d'Amérique du Sud et la plupart
ne s'était pas vu depuis très
longtemps des hommes se signent d'autres
salutent d'autres compte avec deux
doigts le V de la
[Applaudissements]
victoire
immédiatement après l'engin blindé qui
porte le circueil du général de Gaulle
la première voiture est
celle où se trouve Madame De
Gaulle
vous voyez apparaître la voiture de
Madame De
Gaulle
et dans un instant vous allez voir le
cortège passer devant le cimetière et
vous apercevrez la tombe où tout à
l'heure le général ne Gaul sera
[Musique]
inhumé
voici le
cimetière et voici la tombe
les fleurs blanches ont été déposées là
à l'intention de Anne de Wall la fille
enterrée ici en
vous allez voir dans un instant précédé
par l'évêque de
Angre Madame De
Gaulle et son fils
Philippe le capitaine de vaisseau
Philippe de
GA puis suivront le général de Boissieux
son
gendre sa femme les petits enfants dont
le jeune Charles de
Gaulle
ce sont 12 garçons de colombelle et de
églises qui vont porter le
cercueil érieur de
l'église
le Saint- syyien qui suit le cercueil
porte lui le livre des Compagnons de la
Libération qui sera tout à l'heure
déposé sur le
[Applaudissements]
cercueil cette église PE
quelques 400 personnes elle est un peu
trop petite pour le monde qui est pressé
cet aprèsmidi un grand nombre des
Compagnons de la Libération é rest
[Musique]
debout c'est l'é de l'angre Monseigneur
[__] qui a concélébré la messe assisté
du curé de Colomb et de François De
Gaulle père blanc et Neve du
général
dusua
[Musique]
Luce
dešim
de
érousalem et Jo au die si
on au nom du Père et du Fils et du
Saint-Esprit
amen la paix soit avec vous mes frères
et et avec votre
esprit nous sommes réunis mes frères
dans
l'unanimité de notre attachement et de
notre reconnaissance au général de
Gaulle que Dieu a rappelé à
lui
chrétien nous sommes unis plus
profondément
encore par notre foi en l'amour fini de
Dieu c'est à lui que nous adressons
notre prière pour Charles de Gaulle pour
sa famille pour la
France afin de nous préparer à offrir le
sacrifice de la
Messe il nous faut d'abord mes
frères demander au
Seigneur d'avoir pitié de nous
d'oublier nos
erreurs nos péchés et de nous
pardonner Seigneur prend pitié
elle est sur cette
parole si nous sommes morts avec lui
avec lui nous
vivrons si nous supportons
lesépreuve avec lui nous
rgnerons si nous
somm
éeur la cérémonie pour ceux qui
sont sur la place et même sur les toits
de
Colombé du Seigneur est
laÂ
l'abondance du
rachat c'est lui qui
rachètera
Israël de
toutes les
Fes
je met mon espoir dans le
Seigneur je suis sur de sa
parole le Seigneur soit avec vous et
avec votre esprit etons notre cœ nous le
tourons
Seigneur vous voyez à gauche le
capitaine de vaisseau Philippe De Gaulle
fils du général et au premier plan cette
ombre agenouillée c'est madame de est
juste et bon de te rendre gloire de
t'offrir notre action de grâce toujours
et en tout lieu à toi Père trèssain Dieu
éternel et tout-puissant par le Christ
notre Seigneur souviens-toi
de Charles de Gaulle que tu as appelé
auprès de toi
aujourd'hui puisqu'il a été baptisé dans
la mort de ton fils accorde-lui de
participer à sa
résurrection le jour où le Christ
ressuscitant les morts rendra nos
pauvres corps pareils à son corps
glorieux madame de GA vient de
communier
puis d'autres membres de sa famille vont
limité
je crois en toi mon
Dieu
je crois en
moi
mystéux
si Pr de
moi
dansi
tu
de
foi
je crois en toi mon
Dieu
[Musique]
je
Seigneur
Jésus que ton jugement ne condamne pas
notre frère
Charles devant toi qui donc serait
trouvé juste si tu ne lui obtiens pas
toi-même le pardon de tous ses
péchés au nom de la vraie
foi nous te recommandons
humblement notre frère Charles de Gaulle
puisqu'il a vécu marqué du signe de la
Trinité qu'il échappe à la condamnation
par le secours de ta
grâce Seigneur toi qui vis et règne pour
les siècles des siècles
Amen
libérine
[Musique]
a
I
[Musique]
quoč
j 15h50 la fin de la messe le cercueil
va maintenant être porté au cimetière
toujours par les 12 jeunes gens de
Colombet
Dieu est
àour
die
es
je
notre
pè nous
contemplons en nos
visages ton
amour derrière le cercueil
l'évêque de
langangre et à ses
côtés Madame De Gaulle
[Musique]
dieune
Dieu
notre
[Musique]
père nous
attendons dans
l'espérance le général de Boissieux sa
femme et la petite Anne suivie de
Charles de
GA puis la sœur aînée du général de
[Musique]
GA dans quelques instants Charles de
Gaulle sera mise en terre dans cette
terre tourmentée dont il a si souvent
parlé dans ses
mémoires
mir
voilà c'est bien là l'inhumation que
Charles de Gaulle souhaitait dans ce
petit cimetière de village près de sa
fille dans cette tombe qu'il voyait de
sa fenêtre de la Boisserie et que sans
doute il regardait
parfois
écoute-mi
coucou
ci qui cro en moi même sil
est et quonque cro moi ne pour
pas Seigneur
pr
OK isons la Prière du
Seigneur notre Père qui est au cieux que
ton nom soit
sanctifié que ton règne vienne que ta
volonté soit faite sur la terre comme au
ciel donne-nous aujourd'hui notre pain
de ce jour pardonnez-nous nos offenses
comme nous pardonnons aussi à ceux qui
nous ont offenser et ne nous soumets pas
à la tentation mais délivre-nous du mal
Seigneur entend ma
prière Seigneur soit avec
N Seigneur notre
Dieu toi qui nous as
aimé tu as donné ton fils pour que tout
homme qui croi en lui ne périsse pas
mais possède la vie
éternelle viens au secours de notre
faiblesse fais grandir dans la
foi ceux qui se confient en amour et
reçoitent dans son paradis Charles de GA
son serviteur et notre
frère que la paix du Seigneur soit
touour avec
lui
et parmi les membres de la famille après
la sœur aînée du général de Gaulle il y
a aussi pour le dernier adieu les deux
vieilles
servantesou pas sur le plateau
merci
16h9 la grille de la Boisserie est
refermée ici Colombet comme vous venez
de le dire la la procession n'est pas
encore achevée mais elle s'achèvera
bientôt les dernières volonté du général
de ont été strictement respecté jusqu'au
bout c'està-dire que c'est dans le
silence et la dignité que 40000
peut-être 50000 hommes et femmes venu
des quatre coins de la France ont rendu
un dernier hommage à Charles de
Gaulle le défilé devant la tombe a
commencé dès la fin de l'office
religieux en tête bien sû venaient les
Compagnons de la Libération portant
épingl sur la poitrine la plaquette de
bronze accrochée par le ruban vert et
noir et derrière eux c'était la foule
une foule digne silencieuse qui
pénétrait en rang par deux à l'intérieur
de ce petit cimetière de campagne qui
évidemment n'avait pas été prévu pour un
tel
hommage à plusieurs reprises les
haut-parleurs du service d'orre
encourageaiit la foule à se disperser à
rejoindre les autocars et à abandonner
l'idée de défiler ce soir devant la
tombe ces recommandations furent assez
peu
écoutées comme me disait un Français
libre venait venu de Bretagne ce n'est
quand même pas aujourd'hui que nous
allons abandonner à la dernière heure
rares furent ceux qui
renonçaient ce défilé risque encore de
se prolonger pendant 1 heure environ
mais ici à Colombet l'ambiance n'est pas
aux grandes phrases ni homélie ni hor
raison funèbre ni discours avait demandé
le général de gaaule je préfère fa donc
m'imposer le silence pour vous laisser
méditer quelques instants sur ces
dernières images de Colombé et vous
permettre d'avoir vous aussi
l'impression de vous incliner devant
cette
tombe
ici Colombet à vous
Paris